WE WILL GO AHEAD AND START THE
WATER PARKS AND WILDLIFE
COMMITTEE --
MEETING TODAY WE WILL START OF
SUBCOMMITTEE WHILE WE WAIT FOR
THE MEMBERS TO ATTEND AND I HAVE
VOLUNTEERED TO CHAIR --
IN THE INTEREST OF TIME.
AND MISTER LEVINE WELCOME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS S. B. SEVEN NINETY
WILL ALLOW --
YOU KNOW I I OF FUND WELL WILL
ENSURE THE ENTITIES WHO A PLAY A
CRITICAL ROLE IN CO MANAGING
RESERVOIRS CAN QUALIFY FOR STATE
FUNDING.
TEMPLATE CLAUDIA IN ZEBRA MUSSEL
PREVENTION PROGRAMS AND CONDUCT
[inaudible]
VULNERABILITY ASSESSMENTS --
I HAVE.
THE VISUAL DISPLAY FEEL.
SELECT THEYDESCRIBE IT.
ABSOLUTELY GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU MISTER LEVINE FOR YOUR
TIME INTEREST ON THIS LEADERSHIP
THESE ARE CLOGGED MUSCLES FROM
LAKE MEAD.
THIS ESSENTIALLY IS A PLASTIC A
TABLET THAT PUT IN THE LAKES
ONLY TOOK ABOUT TWO WEEKS FOR
THESE MUSCLES.
TO GET TO WHERE THEY ARE.
DEVASTATING LITTLE* AS
SENATOR MCGUIRE LIKE TO SAY IT'S
A BEFORE WE CAN THOUGHT TEN YOU
CAN YOU STATE YOUR NAME PLEASE
ACTUALLY BRATCHER WOULD --
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS MANAGER FOR
CINEMA WATER THANK YOU THANK YOU
CONTINUE WITH THE LITTLE*
OVER THERE OKAY HAVE THE LITTLE
*.
INCOME EVERYONE CALM.
BOB ESSENTIALLY S. NUMBER WATER
WHERE A A WHOLE STILL WATER
SUPPLIER FOR SIX HUNDRED
THOUSAND RESIDENTS IN THE NORTH
BAY.
WE CO MANAGED TO READ THE BOARDS
WITH THE U. S. ARMY CORPS OF
ENGINEERS LIKE CINEMA AND
LAKEMAN THE SCENE NOW.
OUR LEGS ARE MUSCLE FREE AS OF
RIGHT NOW.
HOWEVER --
WE DID FIND A BOAT WITH THESE
QUADRA MUSCLES ON THEM IN JUNE
OF THIS YEAR.
LUCKILY THE BOAT DID NOT GET IN
OUR WATER WAY BECAUSE WE SELF
FUNDED.
MUSCLE SNIFFING DOGS AT OUR BOAT
RAMPS THE DOG SNIFFED OUT THE
MUSCLES BEFORE THE BOAT GOT ON
THEIR WATER WAY.
THE KEYWORD THERE IS SELF FUNDED.
WE WERE NOT AND ARE NOT
CURRENTLY ABLE TO APPLY FOR
STATE GRANT FUNDING.
FROM THE MULTIPLE ATTENTION
PROGRAM UNDER THE CURRENT
STATUTE LAW LANGUAGE.
THIS BILL WOULD HELP US BE ABLE
TO BE CO PARTNERS WITH THE ARMY
CORPS OF ENGINEERS.
ACCESS THAT MUCH NEEDED FUNDING
SO WE CAN PUT A MANDATORY FULL.
INSPECTION PROGRAM IN PLACE
RIGHT AWAY AYE IT'S IS A GREAT
PROGRAM IT'S A GREAT GRANT.
WE NEED ACCESS TO IT AS TWO
OTHER LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WHO CO
MANAGER AS A BORDERS WITH THE
ARMY CORPS TO OTHER PARTNERS SO
WE DO SUPPORT THIS BILL WE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER OF WITNESSES
AND SOME.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
I A CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME IS
GERRY DESMOND WITH RECREATIONAL
BOATERS OF CALIFORNIA WE DON'T
HAVE A POSITION ON THE BILL ITS
CURRENT TIME.
WE'RE VERY FAMILIAR WITH THE
CLOCK RA IN ZEBRA MUSSEL
PROBLEMS OF THE NEED TO HAVE
INSPECTIONS OF BOATS.
A WE ARE VERY UP CAUTIOUS AND
LOOK AT THE BILL IN ITS CURRENT
FORM AND WILL I NOTE THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT OUR COMMUNITY.
THAT THE BOATERS WHO PAY THE
FEES FOR THIS PROGRAM THAT THE
PROGRAM IN THE GRANT FUNDS ARE
RELATED TO BOATING RELATED
ACTIVITIES AT THESE RESERVOIRS.
AB ABOUT FIRST GLANCE IN THE
BILL LOOKS LIKE THAT NEXUS IS
THERE BUT WE WANTED TO MAKE SURE
TO APPEAR AND MAKE SURE OUR THAT
OUR OPPOSITION IS KNOWN.
AND WE APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS TO
WORK ON THE VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE
OF MAKING SURE THAT THESE
INFESTATIONS DO NOT OCCUR
BECAUSE THEY'RE VERY TRAUMATIC.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY ONE IN OPPOSITION.
KATE THANK YOU ANY QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
HEARING NONE WE WILL CONTINUE
THE CONVERSATION WE HAVE A
QUORUM MUCH THANK YOU UP WHICH
LIKE THE CLOTHES THAT FIT.
WHEN YOU HAVE A QUORUM IRISH BUT
THAT'S WHEN I GO THANK YOU YOU
[inaudible]
MARK.
THAT IS A THE MUSCLES YOU DON'T
WANT.
WHO WILL MUCH OF
[inaudible]
POINT THANK YOU WILL TAKE A
MOMENT TO ESTABLISH COR
[inaudible]
EDUARDO GARCIA [inaudible]
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
HERE [inaudible]
BIGELOW [inaudible]
CARILLO [inaudible]
CHOI [inaudible]
CHIU FRIEDMAN.
GLORIA HARPER PRESENT KALRA
[inaudible]
LEVINE.
MATHIS.
RUBIO HERE SALAS WOULD.
THANK YOU WE HAVE A QUORUM AND
AT THIS POINT WE CAN --
IF WE CAN HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND FOR OF MR LEVIN'S BILL.
ARE MCGUIRE SET SB.
SEVEN NINETY THANK YOU HAVE A
MOTION BY MISTER.
SEC MY MS FREEMAN.
CAN YOU CALL THE ROLL PLEASE
[inaudible]
EDUARDO GARCIA [inaudible]
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
GALLAGHER I BIGELOW [inaudible]
BIGELOW AYE [inaudible]
CARILLO [inaudible]
CARILLO I CHOI [inaudible]
CHIU I FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN I GLORIA [inaudible]
HARPER.
HARPER AYE UNA [inaudible]
LEVINE [inaudible]
LEVINE I MATHIS.
MATHIS I RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SALAS WOULD.
EDUARDO GARCIA BY GARCIA I ZERO
ALRIGHT THE WILL LEAVE THAT OPEN
LIKE THAT MEMBER TO WRITE THAT
WILL LET ON THANK YOU.
BUT YOU STILL HAVE NOT HEARD.
PLEASE PROCEED YEAH.
OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
SO BLOOM THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS AB FIFTEEN SEVENTY THREE
WILL PROVIDE CLEAR DIRECTION AND
AUTHORITY TO THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE.
TWO ESTABLISH A STATE
EXPERIMENTAL FISHING PERMIT
PROGRAM THAT WILL SPUR COST
EFFECTIVE IMPROVEMENTS IN STATE
FISHERIES MANAGEMENT.
IT'S BILLS THE REINTRODUCTION OF
AB TWELVE TWENTY EIGHT AND
CONTAINS PROVISIONS THAT WERE
NEGOTIATED BETWEEN MY OFFICE
SPONSORS IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE.
CALIFORNIA'S BEEN LEADING THE
NATION AND WORLD AND CLIMATE
CHANGE POLICY AND SUSTAINABILITY
PRACTICES THIS BILL ENSURES THAT
OUR FISHERY PRACTIES.
JOIN IN THAT FIGHT WITH ME I
HAVE LUCAS FOR REX FROM THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY SPONSORS OF
THE MEASURE.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS GOOD MORNING
LOOK AT FACTS ABOUT THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY WERE STRONGLY
SUPPORTIVE OF AB FIFTEEN SEVENTY
THREE WAS CUT TO THE CHASE IN
ORDER TO AND IT CREATE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR INNOVATION IN
SCIENCE MANAGEMENT CALIFORNIA
STATE MATCH FISHERIES.
AND WE NEED THE BEST AVAILABLE
FISHERIES SCIENCE AND DATA WHICH
IS WHY IT'S CURRENTLY SORELY
LACKING WHICH IS WHY WE NEED THE
EXPERIMENT FISHERIES PERMIT
PROGRAM.
AND WE RESPECTFULLY ASK DR VOTE
ON AB FIFTEEN CITY.
THREE THANK YOU ANYONE WISHING
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE.
PARK BENCH TO MAKE ON BEHALF OF
THE ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND
AND SUPPORT [inaudible]
ANYWHERE ELSE.
IN WHICH YOU SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY BRINGING A BACK THERE'S A
MOTION THE SECOND LIKE CLOTHES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
MOTION IS --
TO LUBA CONCUR IN SENATE
AMENDMENTS [inaudible]
LOCAL.
MOTION ESTA CONCURRENT SENATE
AMENDMENTS EDUARDO GARCIA GARCIA
AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE CHOI.
CHU.
CHU AYE FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN AYE GLORIA.
HARPER BUT HARPER AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE LEVINE.
LEVINE I MATHIS.
MATHIS AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SALAS WOULD.
ABILITY THIS OPEN FOR THE PUBLIC
MEMBERS TO ADD ON THAT YEAH.
THANK YOU MISTER.
YEP I MEAN [inaudible]
I'M [inaudible]
YEAH. FOR MEMBERS ARE NOT HERE
FIVE MINUTES WE'RE GOING TO BE
OPENED WILL ADD ON TO COUPLE OF
OF THE BILLS. SEVEN NINETY KALRA
[inaudible]
KALRA AYE
.
THE OTHERS RUBIO WHO'S WRITTEN.
S. B. SEVEN NINETY THE MOTION IS
TO PASS GLORIA [inaudible]
GLORIA I AB FIFTEEN SEVENTY
THREE MOTION IS TO CONCURRENT
SENATE AMENDMENTS GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE
[inaudible]
YEAH DOT [inaudible]
BOCANEGRA CORPORATE.
THAT WOULD BE GREAT. FOR ONE
NINE O'CLOCK ROLLED AROUND NOT
NOT A PROBLEM BUT FOR MORE
MESSAGES [inaudible]
YEAH
OPEN IT UP BUT FOR
ADDITIONAL ADD ON TUCKED UP CHOI
[inaudible]
SO [inaudible]
IT'S VERY
.
OKAY WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
ANOTHER MINUTE OR TWO AND THAT
WE WILL CLOSE IT UP
BUT IT UP.
THE MEMBER TO ADD ON MAYBE